>> BIG SURPRISE.
WHAT THEY DON'T REPORT IS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE GAVE UP
NOTHING FOR THE RELEASE OF THE
THREE HOSTAGES.
THEY'RE HOME FROM NORTH KOREA.
KIM JONG-UN NEEDS THE SUMMIT
MORE THAN THE U.S.
HERE WITH US, SEAN SPICER IS
WITH US AND ARI FLEISCHER,
FORMER PRESS SECRETARY.
IT'S A SAD POSITION FOR
DEMOCRATS TO BE IN.
ALL THESE 14 RECORD STATES ON
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT, ALL THE
DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHICS ON LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT RECORDS, YOU KNOW,
THE PRESIDENT, NORTH KOREA IS A
GREAT THING.
FOR THEM TO BE HAPPY, HE HAS TO
FAIL.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
BUT I HAVE A SURPRISING
CONCLUSION HOW BAD IT IS WITH
THE PRESS.
IT'S GOOD FOR REPUBLICANS.
BECAUSE THE PRESS IS SO
SEPARATING ITSELF FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY IN
THE BATTLEGROUND STATES, THE
DEMOCRATS READ THEIR GOOD
FAVORABLE PRESS CLIPS AND READ
THE TRUMP CLIPS AND THEY BELIEVE
THEM.
THE MORE THEY BELIEVE THE GOOD
PRESS THEY'RE GETTING, THE MORE
THEY SEPARATE THEMSELVES FROM
THE VOTERS.
THE PRESS HAS SEPARATED
THEMSELVES FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SO YOU HAVE A SLICE LEFT THAT
BELIEVES THE PRESS.
>> Sean: YOU MIGHT BE THE LAST
PRESS SECRETARY THAT EVER HAD A
CHANCE AT THAT JOB.
I WATCH SEAN SPICER WHO DID --
SEAN, I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DID
THAT JOB.
THEY CAN'T PAY NUMBER ENOUGH.
AND SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS IS
AMAZING.
SHE HAS THE PATIENCE OF JOBE.
I COULD NOT DO THE JOB THAT YOU
TWO HAVE DONE.
>> THE WOUNDS ARE FINALLY
STARTING TO HEAL.
I WOULD AGREE -- CAN I JUST SAY
SOMETHING ON NORTH KOREA THOUGH?
THE FUNNY PART IS, ALL THE CLIPS
FORGET WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
AT THE BEGINNING.
IF WE GET A DEAL, GREAT.
I MIGHT WALK OUT.
HE LAID THE PREDICATE FOR THIS A
LONG TIME AGO.
EVERYBODY IS FORGETTING HOW HE
APPROACHED THIS TO BEGIN WITH.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE VERY
CLEAR HE'S WILLING TO MEET WITH
HIM BUT WILLING TO WALK AWAY.
THAT'S WHAT ALL THE PEOPLE HAVE
NOR GOTTEN.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
HE'S GOTTEN KIM JONG-UN TO GIVE
THREE AMERICAN HOSTAGES BACK,
GOTTEN TO START TALKING ABOUT
DENUCLEARIZING THE CLEAN
PENINSULA.
SO MANY MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
ARE BENEFITTING AND THEY'RE
DOING WHATEVER THEY CAN TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT NEGATIVE NEWS TO
COVER.
WHAT IS SO FASCINATING, MOST
AMERICANS ARE SAYING THIS
PRESIDENT IS GETTING THINGS DONE
AND KEEPING HIS PROMISES AND
AMERICA IS BETTER FOR IT.
SO I KNOW FOR A LOT OF FOLKS IN
THE PRESS CORPS, THEY'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE WHAT ELSE CAN I GO AT
HIM ON?
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THEY SHOW
HOW WILDLY OUT OF TOUCH THEY ARE
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE PRESIDENT IS GETTING RESULTS
DOMESTICALLY AND FOREIGN
POLICY-WISE HE'S KEEPING THE
COUNTRY SAFE, DEVELOPING JOBS,
CREATING A ROBUST ECONOMY --
>> GO BACK TO NORTH KOREA FOR A
SECOND.
IF TRUMP DECIDES HE'S NOT GOING
TO GO, THE PRESS WILL BLAME
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF KIM JONG-UN DECIDES HE'S NOT
GOING TO GO, THE PRESS WILL
BLAME TRUMP.
THEY WON'T BLAME THE DICTATOR.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT NO ROCKETS
FIRED OVER JAPAN, THE DMZ?
>> THEY COVERED THE HOSTAGES BUT
IT WAS A ONE-DAY STORY.
JILL ABRAMSON CALLS THEM THE
FAKE NEWS, SHE SAYS THEY HEAR
THE CASH REGISTER.
PEOPLE ARE SUBSCRIBING ONLINE IS
SO OPPOSITIONAL TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP -- IT'S THE VOICE OF THE
OPPOSITION.
NEWSPAPERS HAVE TO BE FACTUAL.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOTTEN LOST.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN HOW
HORRIBLE CNN -- I WANT RESIDUALS
FROM CNN AND MSNBC.
THEY RUN ME ALL THE TIME.
THEY NEED TO PAY ME.
ZUCKER NEEDS TO PAY ME.
THEY'RE NOT DOING WELL WITH
THIS.
IF I WAS WATCHING A PRESIDENT
GIVE A SPEECH AND THEY CHANTED
FOX NEWS SUCKS, I MIGHT TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY AFTER A WHILE.
>> THE FUNNY THING ON MY ENDS,
DURING THE CAMPAIGN SEASON, I
WAS PUBLIC.
I GAVE CREDIT TO CNN IN TERMS OF
HOW THEY COVERED THE CAMPAIGN,
HOW THEY RAN THEIR DEBATE.
SUDDENLY JANUARY 11 WHEN JIM
ACOSTA DECIDED TO BECOME A
CARNIVAL BARKER, THEY DECIDED TO
CHANGE THEIR MODEL AND REALIZED
IT WAS TO FOLLOW MSNBC AND BE
THE OTHER RESISTANCE.
IT'S SAD.
THEY MADE IT PERSONAL AND THEIR
RAIDINGS ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE
OF IT.
EVERY ONE OF THESE HOSTS GOES ON
AIR AND TRIES TO OUTDUE EACH
OTHER.
>> AND THE PROBLEM IS THE PRESS
SHOULD BE THE RESISTANCE.